all right everybody it is time for
drew's news it's that good news glue
that's holding us all together and with
me at the desk is a man that literally
holds me together rosty russ matthews
hi drew
hi um by the way congratulations are in
order
well we made it to season three
[Music]
[Applause]
high five high five
we're
so excited and that one i'm like okay
yay few relief we're safe
relief is such an underrated emotion
right um but this one i actually feel
like i gotta shout from the rooftops um
so i just found out this morning that
the webby awards are coming up this
month and guess what rossy i know drew
we are nominated
this is insane this is huge
for best podcast like it's funny season
three i'm like
okay great we made it this one i'm like
um yeah it's for best podcast and um you
have to see this image because i'm in
between jon stewart and stephen colbert
look at you and i've got to just say
best sandwich of my life right
[Applause]
so thank you webbies it's an honor to be
nominated we want to like show up and go
to the party and just see what happens
and i'm just we're the only female uh
show interestingly
and uh the only show in daytime all the
others are late night which also makes
me
so proud
and you're the
the meat in that podcast sandwich i am
the meat i'm very excited
um well another comedy icon literally i
think a gentleman who has saved all of
our souls in so many ways jim carrey
has just sort of
announced
that he might be ready to retire so
variety reports that he says he possibly
might be done with acting he's in the
new sonic the hedgehog sequel which
we'll be seeing opening day with my
girls we went and saw the first one
and he's thinking it might be his grand
finale jim says quote i have enough i've
done enough i am enough
and he says that if the perfect script
dropped down from heaven i mean he's had
it happen before eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind the truman show
dumb and dumber i mean the the
oh my god um he says that he might be
open to doing it um but right now he's
focusing on his painting and we have a
picture of him painting and if he
doesn't look cute as a button right
what's your favorite jim carrey movie
well i think i mean it has to be dumb
and dumber or the truman show probably a
man on the moon remember man on the moon
i do
there's so many what's yours
i i think it's dumb and dumber um
because lloyd christmas is you know he's
just he lives in my heart
um i quote jim and chummer pretty much
every day of my life give me a quote um
i mean um you want to hear the most
annoying sound in the world
or you know
these rockies are you know flat that's
john denver's full of bees
i always do what's the soup du jour the
soup of the day i'll have that that
sounds good i'll have that
yeah you know i i love jim carrey and i
as much as i like when i heard he was
thinking about retiring i was like no we
need you now more than ever but i also
kind of love that he's in this position
in his life where he can just sort of
say i've done that i love his quote i
have enough i've done enough i love him
i love him too and i love retirement
no i'll tell you i do love retirement
you know when when
when i'm not here in new york with you
drew i'm in palm springs and i live my
life like an active senior i am like
like i wear comfortable shoes i have a
sensible bedtime i mean give me a
werther's original and put me to bed
that's how i live my life so welcome to
the club jim carrey welcome to
retirement
[Music]